hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
sample collection and transport in the
age of kovid a retrospective what have
we learned
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by copan diagnostics to learn more
visit copanusa
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr susan e sharp scientific director
copan diagnostics
susan you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you and hello everyone i
would like to start by thanking lab
roots and thanking copan for asking me
to present today and to thank all of you
for attending today
we're going to spend some time talking
about sample collection and transport in
the age of covid we're going to look at
what's been going on over the last year
and what we've learned from a sample
collection
um
age um and
basically over the history of the last
year so let's get started we're going to
have a few objectives today
we're going to go over again and make
sure that we recognize what is the gold
standard for sample collection for
respiratory viruses
and then we're going to spend some time
and go over how sample collection
devices
the swabs themselves the collection
devices as well as the transport media
changed over time and with the fda as we
moved forward last year in the emergency
use authorization process for testing
and lastly we'll discuss a few issues
including the quality procedures that
are used in swab manufacturing
self-collection of specimens um a little
information about some at home and
over-the-counter testing that's
available for covid and then just lastly
talk about a few differences in the
methodologies that we have out there for
testing for coding
so first to recognize the gold standard
gold standard for sample collection for
respiratory viruses
and you might think that's kind of weird
that i'm showing you a picture of um
soda
when i'm going to be talking about swabs
but i do this to make us make a point as
you can see these are all different
types of soda or soda pop or whatever
you call them but obviously they're much
different from one another
and the same thing is uh can be said for
swabs and collection media
there's lots of different types of swabs
and many different types of collection
media and
as
we know with soda
all swabs in all collection media are
not created equal
swabs and collection devices do have to
have an establishment registration and a
device listing with the fda
and this is just an example
of one from copan diagnostics and again
it's a it's an establishment
registration that lists the devices this
is for copan you can see that there's a
registration number associated with that
and then at the bottom it shows the
different types of applicators and
collection devices that
copan has listed with the fda
in this establishment registration
and again that is required
for all
collection devices in the u.s
so let's start by talking about our
traditional fiber wrap swabs now these
are swabs as you can see that have just
a stick associated with them and then
the fiber is wrapped around the end of
the stick to make this
a mattress core if you will
now these spun or wrapped swabs are
usually made out of polyester
or rayon and again it um
uh wrapping them on to the end of the
stick
you'll see there's a swab at the end
that is made up of a lot of a lot of
these wrapped fibers as you can see in
the insert picture now when you absorb a
sample onto a traditional fiber wrapped
swab a lot of the sample will get
trapped on the inside although these can
absorb a decent amount of sample it's
very difficult sometimes to get this
trapped sample on the inside of all
these different fibers actually out of
the swab once collected
so copian even invented the nylon
flocked swab and as you can see here uh
in the upper left
rather than being just a uh a stick
applicator it has a molded head as you
can see here
and
this is important because when the flock
swabs are made as you can see on the
right hand picture we start with that
molded head top
we then add glue to the top to that
molded head
and at the next stage we um what
undergo what's called the flocking
process this is where you take very
small little fibers
of nylon
and you flop them onto the outside of
the molded head so
millions of these little fibers are
blown onto
the
the head of the swab that is covered
with the glue and they stick
into the glue and you end up with a swab
that looks like this
so again the swab the flock swab is made
out of nylon and it's made out of these
millions of very small nylon
strands that are coated uh
onto the head of this um elongated swab
here or molded swab as you can see
now flock swamps as you can see in the
on the
left hand side
come in all different kinds of sizes and
shapes depending on what you're going to
use them for
and again with the nylon flax swab as
much as 90 of the sample will elude out
of the swab very rapidly and again this
is because it doesn't have that mattress
core that will maintain some of the
specimen and not allow it to come back
out
and that is shown in this slide as you
can see on the top there's a traditional
fiber swab um the sample
once it's taken
with the swab
you put it into a liquid media a lot of
the sample will become trapped in that
fiber mattress and not elute out into
the liquid volume as you can see in the
upper panel
but with the flopped swab
excuse me this brush-like texture
efficiently collects specimens from the
respiratory tracts
including cells and fluid
the sample stays very close to the
surface and the loose out very rapidly
in the transport media as you can see in
the slide on the right on the bottom
right much more of the specimen was
actually eluded
off of the
flock swab that is able to be eluded off
the traditional spun or wrapped swabs
now i i'm going to talk a little bit
about absorption and aleutian volumes
later and i'll uh or now then i'll tell
you a little bit later about why this is
so important in the swab manufacturing
process
but with the swabs
we're all aware that there's regular
type swabs as you can see in this
picture they can be again made out of
that wrapped or spun fiber that makes
that mattress core they can also be made
out of foam or they can be made out of
the flock process which i just described
to you
so in the center you can see the
absorption volume for each one of these
irregular type swabs and the regular
type swabs would be a swab that would be
used for a nasal specimen or a throat
collection specimen and as you can see
in comparing these three different types
of swab that the regular phlox swab
absorbs the most volume over 150
microliters is absorbed onto the swa the
swab compared with foam which absorbs
only 38 microliters and a regular
traditional
wrapped fiber swab or spun swab which
will absorb around 100 microliters and
then if you look at the release volume
again the regular wrapped fiber swab
will release around uh or
release around 58 to 64
of its specimen that it absorbed the
foam swab releases about 85 but again
the flock swab releases the maximum
amount of specimen 94 of the specimen
that is absorbed onto the flux swab will
then be alluded
into the specimen into the transport
media
also if you look at the mini tipped
swabs these are the swabs that would be
used for
for a nasal pharyngeal collection for
example so they have a much smaller tip
on the end as you can see and again
these
mini tips can be made again from wrapped
fiber or they can be made from flocked
nylon and again looking at the
absorption volume you can see that the
traditional mini tipped wrapped or spun
fiber swabs absorbs about uh
25 to 30 microliters as compared to the
mini tipped flock swab which will absorb
64.
and again much better um release volume
or elusion volume associated with the
minitex uh mini tipped flock swab at 96
compared to the fiber wrapped swab
at 65 to 70
so that was talking about the swabs and
as i said they're not all created equal
and now you understand why um there's
also a variety of different transport
media that have come into use during the
covid
pandemic and first is viral transport
media this is an example of utm which
stands for universal transport media it
is an fda cleared collection and
transport system that's suitable for the
collection and transport assessments to
the laboratory either at room
temperature or at refrigerator
temperatures and you can also maintain
these in long-term freezer storage
for weeks to months as well
for your clinical specimens
now viral transport media is an open
platform this type of a specimen
collection can be used either for viral
culture for enzyme immunoassays for
direct fluorescent antibodies and even
for nucleic acid amplification tests or
molecular tests
and um numerous studies are out there
that have showed that if you take a
a utm viral transport medium and you
pair it with a flocked nasopharyngeal
swab so one of those mini tips locked
nylon swabs that it is equivalent
to nasal aspirates and nasal washes for
the diagnosis of respiratory viral
infections
now amy's media is a media that's been
around a long time in microbiology
for copan we have amy's media included
into our e-swab which is a flocked swab
with one mil of amy's media in a plastic
screw cap tube as you can see in the
picture now this is normally used for
the collection and transport of aerobic
anaerobic and fastidious bacteria to the
laboratory
for up to uh keeping the organism stable
for up to 48 hours but you'll see in a
slide coming up that amy's media was
also used uh for a collection specimen
um early on in the covid pandemic
another media is nucleic acid
stabilization media and these are
guanidine thiocyanate based media uh
copan also produces one of these uh
types of tubed media called the enac and
again
because it does have the guanodine
thiocyanate in it it stabilizes both rna
and dna of viruses and bacteria so it
ensures the preservation of the nucleic
acid at room temperature for weeks or
even months if the specimen is frozen
and one thing to remember about these
guanidine thiocyanate based mediums is
that they do inactivate microbial uh
viability and activity so it allows for
state safe specimen handling but you
will not be able to recover the organism
or grow the organism from these nucleic
acid stabilization media
and one other note uh about the
stabilization media is that the fda has
put out a note um about um the use of
these media in the laboratory uh this
transport media these um that have the
guanodine thiocyanate um if it is
exposed uh exposed to bleach it can
produce a very dangerous cyanide gas so
there is a warning
uh associated with these types of uh
collection media when used for a cobia
diagnosis
especially on two
high throughput platforms uh the hologic
panther and the panther fusion systems
they do use a disinfectant step of
bleach on their platform so again
because bleach can interact uh with the
guanidine thiocyanide in the transport
media and produce that dangerous gas it
is recommended that these uh
stabilization medias are not used with
either one of these two platforms
so our second objective was to talk
about the and describe the generation of
the different specimen types collection
devices and transport media that evolved
early on during the coven pandemic
so everyone remembers that very early on
um the the first emergency use
authorization assay for covid that was
authorized by the food and drug
administration went to the cdc and this
was in early in february of last year
that fa used either a nasopharyngeal
swab or an oral pharyngeal swab or a
throat swab that was made out of nylon
or polyester and the specimen had to be
transported to the laboratory in a viral
transport media
and after that first assay additional
swab types collection sites and
transport medias were then also given
emergency use authorization by the fda
so let's talk about those
so again um as i already said the cdc
assay was the first emergency use
authorization given um by the fda at
that time and the specimens had to be
collected by a healthcare worker again
they could be nasopharyngeal or oral
pharyngeal collection by the healthcare
worker they could be flocked to nylon
swabs or polyester swabs in viral
transport media
now soon after the cdc assay uh was
given an emergency use authorization the
fda also added on the ability to um use
either liquid amy's
came first and then phosphate buffered
saline came next again due to the
um overloaded specimens and the
difficulty in getting viral transport
media um there was data out there to
show that liquid amy's would also hold
viruses stably for a number of hours or
days and also phosphate buffered saline
so the fda did authorize the use of
these other two transport medias early
on as well
after this
the mid-turbinate swab which is also a
flocked swab which goes halfway between
the anterior neres and the nasal
pharyngeal
part of the back of the throat anatomy
so it goes halfway between so it's
called the mid-terminate it's a phlox
swab was also
approved for use as were nasal swabs
and in addition to the nylon flock or
polyester swabs the fda in march
later on in march also approved
the ability to use a foam swab as well
by early april uh the cdc also also i'm
sorry also authorized another transport
media to go along with the viral
transport media the liquid amy's the
phosphate buffered saline and they added
normal saline as well
by the middle of april
um they also added
another collection type of material that
could be used for nasal swabs um and
that was be able to use rayon so not
only could we use nylon
polyester foam
by mid april rayon was also
approved as was
another transport media which was the
nucleic acid stabilization media that
we've talked about
and then in may
up until this time most of this testing
had to be done by a healthcare worker
either at a healthcare facility or at a
drive-through facility and in early may
the fda also approved the use of home
collection for some covet assays as well
so home collection of the specimens that
you would then send in to the laboratory
for testing
so the um the fda continues to uh
indicate to us that the sample
collection with a flop swab when
available is preferred but there are
other types of swabs um that can be
appropriate for collection as well which
are listed here on the slide for you
again a nasopharyngeal uh specimen
should be collected by a healthcare
worker using one of those specialized
mini tip swab and again according to the
fda the nasopharyngeal floc swab is
still the
collection of choice
but you can also use
oropharyngeal specimens or regular sized
uh swabs a full tips full tip swab
and these originally were also needed to
be collected by healthcare providers
mid-terminus specimens also should be
collected by a health care provider or
they can be collected on site
by the patient themselves under the
supervision of a health care worker
using a flocked mid-turbinate
swab lastly as we said that the fda did
approve anterior neres specimen
collections with a routine
a full-size tip swab again this can be
collected by a health care provider or
on-site self-collection using a
full-size flock swap or a round swab or
a fiber wrapped swab and we knew we know
soon after this home collection of nasal
swabs came later as well as did home
testing and we'll talk a little bit
about those in a bit
so i'd like to go over a few studies on
this slide and the next next slide to
give you an idea of what formed these
initial fda guidances there were some um
papers published in the literature early
on and the fda used some of these papers
to help inform their guidance on
specimen collection for covid the first
study was done at the everett clinic
and they wanted to evaluate
self-collection
from different sites in the body
so they looked at nasopharyngeal
collections nasal collections
mid-turbinate and tongue collections
now you can see on the swab type i have
comparator on this slide next to the
nasal pharyngeal in a yellow highlight
and that's because i wanted to uh point
out that in this study they did use a
nasopharyngeal to compare the rest of
these swabs and these the rest of these
collections too but the nasopharyngeal
swab they used in this particular study
was a
fiber wrapped swab so it was not a nylon
flock swab so just keep that in mind as
we go through
so they wanted to clear these different
types of swabs from self-collection that
were then put into viral transport media
and tested at the laboratory and as you
can see over to the far right
as compared to the uh the wrapped uh
swab that was collected by the
healthcare worker and then um
uh collect compared to these other
collection a self-collected
mid-terminated specimen had about 96
sensitivity as compared to the
healthcare collected
fiber wrapped nasopharyngeal swab
a self-collected nasal specimen had
about 94
accuracy as compared to the
nasopharyngeal swab and the tongue
collected specimen was was not very good
the sensitivity of the tongue collected
specimen fell well short uh being less
than 90 when collect when compared to
the nasopharyngeal swab
the next study the second study was done
at uh stanford they wanted to look at
also itself collection from nasal
passages so all that they um compared uh
throat collected specimens to nasal foam
collected specimens also submitted in
vtm and tested in the laboratory
and they found that the nasal swab that
was collected by the healthcare worker
was equivalent to the oropharyngeal swab
also collected
by the healthcare worker
they also
found that the nasal swab if
self-collected was also equivalent in
sensitivity to the throat swab collected
by the healthcare worker
so again you can see this these studies
informed what types of specimens
could be collected what kind of swab
should be used and what kind of what
type of transport media can be used
the third study was again done at the
everett clinic and the everett clinic
is in seattle in washington state um one
of the very uh first outbreaks of cova
that was seen in this country
so the second study they did at the
everett clinic in seattle was to
evaluate alternative polyester swab and
evaluate alternative transport medias
so again they looked at all nasal
specimens in this third study they
looked at foam and polyester submitted
in viral transport media and then they
looked at foam and polyester nasal swabs
submitted in saline
and they were able to show that the
polyester suave was equivalent to the
foam nasal swab when submitted in btm
and that the also the polyester swab was
equivalent to the foam nasal swab when
submitted in saline again um
giving more information to the the fda
on what was appropriate um
specimens to collect either foam or
polyester and also saline work quite
well as well the last study on this page
also wanted to evaluate
the
impact that heat might have on these
specimens so they looked at nasal
collected specimens again from covid
patients
they looked at foam collections as well
as polyester collections submitted dry
and in saline and tested in the
laboratory and as you can see in the
little chart on the bottom right hand
side that
at 32 degrees slightly above um room
temperature
the foam dry swab the polyester dry swab
and the polyester saline swab
the first two that were dry
the virus was stable for up to 80 hours
at 32 degrees went down a little bit
with the polyester saline
swabs went down to about 56
hours of stability at 32 degrees but
looked what happened to all three of
these types of specimens when they were
transported at uh 440 degrees much
higher you can see that the the
stability of the samples to be tested in
the laboratory um were only able to be
maintained for up to 12 hours
the last two studies i want to share
with you um there's a big study done by
quest
early on during the pandemic where they
evaluated the stability of the virus and
transport media under various storage
conditions
what they did is they took nasal
pharyngeal specimens throat specimens
sputums
and sputus specimen and bal that they
received tested for cova that were
negative and then they spiked these
samples
with covered virus and and tested them
in the laboratory they used a variety of
different swab types they used a variety
of different transport media they use
utm m4 they use amy's in e-swabs and
they also use saline
and they tested these in the laboratory
and overall with these spike samples um
in the transport media they were able to
show that the ct values were stable
when the specimens were stored at minus
30 degrees celsius celsius all the way
up to 25 degrees celsius for up to 7 to
10 days
so good stability um
when stored appropriately
and then the last study i want to share
with you also out of seattle evaluated
the use of
dry mid-turbinate phlox swabs compared
to those swabs that were submitted in
vtm um this is for studying um the
impact that a dry swab might have in
home collection kits and their
preliminary results demonstrated that
the dry swabs would indeed support
detection of sarco v2 for a limited
amount of time without impacting the
sensitivity of the assay
so our last objectives today we're going
to um
talk about a few other issues that we
went over when we talked about our
objectives but the first one we're going
to talk about is quality procedures in
swab manufacturing
as i said
um
swab collection devices are considered
class 1 devices by the fda and as such
they do have requirements
that have to be
met in order to get this
device listing in order to meet these
requirements analytical studies must be
done sterilization studies must be done
and then packaging and labeling studies
must be done and submitted to the fda
so first the analytical studies
these studies are done because we know
that swabs need to be
certified to be non-toxic
non-irritating and non-sensitizing
uh for limited contact that they're
going to have when they come in contact
with with the human
whether that's the nasal passages the
throat the nasopharyngeal etc
and copan goes to great lengths to
ensure that all components including our
glue our fiber and our plastics comply
with very rigorous biocompatibility
standards that are necessary
from the fda
another area of empire importance and
high focus for copant is mechanical
safety
continual quality control is performed
to ensure that certain mechanical
standards are met
including applicator flexibility
fragility
fiber detachments
and durability after sterilization
including tensile testing torsional
testing and flexural testing and this
will become important in a couple slides
when i uh
talk to you about another study that was
done
swabs also need to show equivalent
performance and adequate collection of
specimens from their intended site
whether that be nasal nasopharyngeal
oral pharyngeal etc so fluid dynamics as
we've already talked about absorption
and release these fluid dynamics are
huge for consideration for manufacturers
and manufacturers must quantify fluid
dynamics for all of these slides
additionally copan has decades of
experience as well as a fully equipped
molecular biology laboratory to ensure
that none of our swab components
interfere with
the chemistries of any of the molecular
assays or antigen assays
as part of our quality control program
we continually test our swabs with
numerous molecular platforms to ensure
that we do have compatibility with all
of these different platforms
now the sterilization process must be
validated by the manufacturer prior to
distribution including the bioburden
testing of the final product which you
can see here
in a panel that's before the
final sterilization product and b after
the final sterilization product and this
is something that's really been taken
for granted in the industry for a long
time
but
um during
the pandemic we all remember seeing
these headlines about contaminated or
non-sterile medical swabs being used for
covid diagnostics
packaging and labeling is also important
as i said um for getting a device
listing with with the fda packaging must
address the seal strength so the
packaging ceiling
of the product must be adequate and it
also addresses the integrity of the
packaging to make sure that it will hold
up during the shipping process
and swabs also must be labeled
appropriately which
will include
their intended use whether they're for
nasal pharyngeal specimens
or whether they're for
nasal specimens throat specimens etc
so it also has to be labeled to include
what the site of application of the
collection device is for
now during covid we know that there were
severe limitations and supply issues
which with getting uh enough swabs for
the the height of the pandemic which we
went through last year and we're going
through again
uh currently so 3d printed swabs became
very popular and were being looked at by
many different individuals
as you can see here there's a lot of
three different 3d printed swabs here
these again are completely made of
plastic on a 3d printer
now when you look at 3d printed swabs
versus the conventional swabs that we
normally saw in manufacturing there were
some user concerns that were reported
to the fda
first it looked that like some of the 3d
printed swabs are very brittle
especially after they were sterilized
they became very brittle and they would
break into multiple sharp pieces which
could injure the patient
and also the non-traditional heads as
you can see in the picture associated
with these different types of swabs were
concerned that they were not appropriate
to sufficient
sufficiently
absorb enough specimen actually to test
appropriately in our testing devices
we know that there was limited
experience and research with these types
of 3d printed swabs although we know we
have a lot of a lot of research over the
last many decades with using traditional
swabs we didn't have a lot of that same
information for using these sweet 3d
printed swabs for diagnostics
and it isn't important that these swabs
be assessed to ensure that they are
properly characterized for
again their intended use and to make
sure that they do meet the clinical need
and there has been a consistency in
these devices also been reported um
saying that if a device even if they use
the same recipe if you will
if they're produced at different
facilities they can have different
characteristics that can affect safety
and efficacy
and that finally the finishing and the
sterilization process associated with
the 3d plastic printed swabs even
printer updates uh that may take place
or among some of the factors that could
affect
how these swabs would function in real
life and because of these concerns the
fda on the bottom of the slide you'll
see there's a link there for you did
publish some guidelines on some
technical considerations
for manufacturers that were making 3d
printed materials
during the covet epidemic including the
3d printed swabs
now
this
as i stated swabs are a class one device
that are registered and listed with the
fda and this was a very interesting
study that looked at the quality and the
performance of collection swabs and
viral transport media from unregistered
manufacturers they looked at five
different manufacturers
they specifically looked at the
assessment criteria to include an
inspection of the the device integrity
they looked at the determination of the
swab and the viral transport media as
far as sterility is concerned and their
in vitro performance
they looked at the stability associated
with the viral transport media and then
overall the um clinical performance of
the device kit so the swab and the viral
transport media together
they did use as their gold standard the
fda registered copan uh
vtm or universal transport media and a
copan flock swab as their comparator
and you can see here this is table four
from that published article that gives
examples of the issues that were found
with these unregistered products
you can see with manufacturer one there
were three out of the ten swabs that had
growth observed in cultures so 3 out of
the 10 swabs were contaminated
they also found that
they looked at 10 different viral
transport media from this manufacturer
and again all 10 of them were also
heavily contaminated
with organisms
manufacture two
about 13 of the viral transport media
containers had uh visible leakage or
they were inconsistent in their fill
volumes same thing with manufacturer
number three four percent of the viral
transport media containers had either
visible leakage or had an inconsistent
field volume associated with them
with manufacture four they again saw
visible growth or discoloration and
leakage in a number of the viral
transport media containers and then in
five they looked at the integrity and
also the in vitro performance of the
swab
um they found with the 3d printed swabs
which was
the swabs that were used from
manufacturer number five that there was
breakage of the stem outside of the
break point and that these um which is
can be a safety hazard for the patient
they also had it had very limited
flexibility of the shaft of the swab and
they also found that they had very poor
transfer effectiveness so they didn't
pick up a lot of swab and they didn't
transfer a lot of swab to the viral
transport media
they were able to show that the ct
values were three to four cycles higher
than that of the referenced
flock swab that they use as a comparator
now there was also a recent
meta-analysis performed by lee and
colleagues that reviewed a tremendous
amount of literature surrounding
specimen collections for the diagnosis
of sars-cov2 infection
and they were able to include in their
analysis
25 citations that evaluated and studied
the use of saliva
11 articles that looked at nasal swabs
six articles that looked at
oropharyngeal swabs
four of them that looked at
oropharyngeal and nasal swab specimens
that were combined and all of these um
were compared to nasopharyngeal swabs as
the gold standard
now three specimen types uh that were
studied all show showed lower positivity
rates as compared to the nasopharyngeal
specimens the nasal
nasal swabs at about 82 percent
sensitivity
the uh throat swabs or the oral
pharyngeal swabs at 84 sensitivity and
saliva at 88 sensitivity
now the combination of the throat swab
and the nasal swab came closer to the
sensitivity of the nasopharyngeal
collection with a performance of 97
percent sensitive
now of note uh nasal swabs in these
studies
that specified that they used a flocked
nasal swab had a substantial higher
positivity rate than studies where an
unflocked nasal swab was used and this
again shows the superiority of the nylon
flux swab
to absorb and release specimen as
compared to our wrapped fiber swabs
so these authors concluded that nasal
pharyngeal specimens remain the gold
standard for the diagnosis of sars kobe
2
and although there are alternative
specimens that might be promising we
still have a lot to know about the
impact of the variation of these
different types of collection devices
um the variation of the people that are
actually collecting the specimens
whether that be a health care worker or
self-collection
processing protocols and laboratories
are different and obviously the
populations that are being tested are
also can be very different as well
so one of the uh last objectives we're
going to talk about with home collection
um home collection
has been around for uh several many
months now if you will
there are several home collection kits
that do have emergency use authorization
from the fda and they come with some
general
outlines of how to collect the specimen
these are usually always anteriornary
specimens that are tested at home in our
community setting so again they usually
use a swab
the swab is either placed in a dry tube
or a media tube and then is sent to the
laboratory in the mail and you notice i
have a little red
um
star there and we'll talk why that's
important remember we had that study
that looked at the stability of the um
viruses being transported at 32 degrees
as opposed to 40 degrees centigrade
and again most of these will come with
some instructions as you can see on the
right hand side to carefully open the
nasal swab so you don't contaminate the
um
uh
the end that you're going to collect
with to gently you know insert into one
nares until you feel a little uh
resistant swab it around about four
times remove it and then do the same
thing in the other nostril
uh place the the swab
with the swab tip first into the media
break it off put the cap on it and again
then put it in a mailer and send it to
the laboratory
and the reason it's so important to
understand um uh when these uh the
effect the temperature can have on these
specimen is because this is a was taken
in july 19th
of last year during the height of some
of the covid um
issues that we're having in the united
states and this simply shows um how hot
some of the
delivery trucks can be this was uh
labeled a heat taking its toll on a ups
driver that has no air conditioning and
if they don't have any air conditioning
in the front of the truck they don't
have any air conditioning in the back of
the truck and you can see that the
temperature reached 152 degrees
fahrenheit
in the back of the truck which is 67
degrees centigrade and remember the
study i showed you about the
significant decrease in
stability of the virus
in the viral nucleic acids when the
temperature increased up to uh even in
the 40s you can imagine what might
happen to the um
stability of the virus and the stability
of the specimens when they're
transported at 67 degrees centigrade so
something we need to keep in mind when
we do home collections and then have
them sent into the laboratory for
testing
now i want to review some at-home tasks
that have gotten some
emergency use authorization from the fda
there are two different types of at-home
tests they can either be tests that are
done um by prescription so your health
care provider would prescribe one of
these tests for you and you would do the
testing at home
or there's also now over-the-counter
test where you do not need a
prescription from a healthcare provider
you can simply walk into your pharmacy
pick up one of these tasks take it
purchase it take it home and do your own
test at home
so there is um there are several
examples i'm just going to go over a
couple of them for you um in november of
last year a molecular prescription at
home test was given an eua or an
emergency use authorization by the fda
and this is from lucera health
um
that invented this one just um
briefly this is how the results are read
again there's very good instructions on
how you collect the specimen the nasal
swab specimen how you do the test but i
wanted to show you to show you this last
slide
where you would read the result and this
test again
is a molecular assay that is done at
your house
the test will be ready in about 30
minutes after you set it up if the
positive light goes green as you can see
on the left hand side
and it the done button is also green
that is a positive result
in the middle if the done button is
green and the negative illuminates green
then that is a negative test
on the far right you can see if all
lights are flashing green then that is
an invalid test so you cannot determine
positivity or negativity from that
and again in their instructions they'll
tell you what to do if you're positive
what to do if you're negative and then
how to dispose of the kit so again an
at-home prescription molecular assay
there's also some at-home
prescription antigen assays that are
also available um that have gotten
emergency use authorization from the fda
two of them are listed here for you uh
one from uh uh quiddell corporation
which was given an eua from the fda in
early march and then one that you're
probably familiar with to the binex now
anagen card home test from abbott
diagnostics which uh received its eua
for prescription at home testing in
december of last year and these are both
lateral flow visual reading assays
quickly to go over the quick view
again
it comes with uh instructions on how to
do the test wash your hands
get your components ready
take your tube out
stick
stand it up in a little platform
cardboard container that comes with the
kit
again take your nasal swab with
instructions on how to appropriately
sample your neries for the test take the
swab out stick it in your medius let it
sit there for a minute or so
then you take the swab out and then you
add in your lateral flow strip
you wait for
an appropriate amount of time 10 minutes
i believe in this assay and then you
interpret your results and it has very
good instructions on what is a positive
result you have to see both a blue and a
pink line in order for it to be positive
if you see only a blue line like on the
bottom left hand side that is a negative
reaction and if you only get a pink line
and no blue line that would be an
invalid result
so again an antigen test for
prescription that you can do at home
there are some over-the-counter assays
as well that you do not need a
prescription from a healthcare provider
in order to do this test um there are a
few there this is the anagen
over-the-counter test that you can pick
up in your drugstore from illume
that was given an eua in february of
this year and again it's an antigen
lateral flow assay
and there's another also another
molecular assay that is over the counter
not prescription that was given in eua
by the fda uh in march of this year from
q health and i just want to spend the
next slide showing you the q health
assay it's really quite fascinating
again it's not prescription so you can
pick this up in your drugstore on the
far
left hand side you can see that it comes
in a box
um with two different packages inside
the first thing you do is that you
download the q health app to your
smartphone
okay
and then you pair the q health app to
the cartridge that was in the box that
you just purchased and that will pair by
bluetooth
and then you connect your reader your
cartridge reader onto a power supply
as you can see in the in the middle you
take your um the test cartridge you put
it into the reader you connect the
reader and then you take your swab as
you can see on the right you collect
your nasal specimen on the bottom you
take that nasal specimen you stick it
into the test cartridge that is sitting
inside the reader and in 20 minutes
again you will get an answer back to
your iphone as to the result of the test
so the last thing we're going to talk
about is the different types of assays
that are currently available on the
market
um and and in laboratories
so these are all um
covid19 assays that have an eua from the
fda i should mention there is one full
approved uh fda kit it is not an
emergency youth
kit it has gone through the um
full fda approval and again it's a test
it's the bio fire assay that is uh done
inside the laboratory environment
but we know for our covet assays we have
molecular assays antigen assays which we
just talked about and also we have our
antibody in our serology assays
now our molecular antigen assays can be
used for diagnostic testing
for screening or for surveillance
so as briefly our molecular tests we
know that they do detect nucleic acids
they're usually more sensitive than our
antigen tests uh they will
pick up your pre-symptomatic individuals
sooner than your anagen tests will
certainly they will detect your
symptomatic patients and you may stay
positive with the molecular tests into
convalescence as well conformation is
usually not needed with a molecular test
our antigen tests we know rather than
detecting nucleic acids will detect
proteins associated with the virus they
are less sensitive than our molecular
tests and confirmation may be needed
with a molecular assay if in fact you
have a patient that has signs of
symptoms of covid you do your antigen
test and it is negative um the clinician
might be advised with these tests that
if the symptoms do look like covet and
you get a negative antigen test that you
may want to confirm this with a
molecular assay
now as i said there's different types of
diagnostic testing for covid diagnostic
testing is when testing is done on an
individual when there is reason to
suspect that they might be infected with
the coping virus so you're testing
symptomatic individuals
or individuals who have had a recent
exposure or people that are at high risk
such as health care professionals that
are taking care of sick patients and
again you do this to determine what
you're going to do with the patient
there's also screening that can be done
and this includes broad testing of
asymptomatic individuals that do not
have a known exposure
but again these are also done with the
intent of making individual decisions
based on those test results for those
patients
and then lastly there's surveillance
testing and this is used to monitor for
an uh an occurrence of an infectious
disease outbreak um so usually they're
not
single patient identifiers associated
with these but it's usually a large um
testing involving a whole community at
one time etc rather than testing on an
individual
level
now diagnostic testing and screening
testing do need to have fda emergency
use authorization or fda approval
surveillance testing when you're doing
community testing out in the community
is not under the fda purview and that
does not need an eua but remember with
surveillance testing you're not testing
individuals and you're not reporting
results back to a health care provider
so that individual decisions can be made
on an individual that is only happening
with diagnostic and screening testing
lastly we know that there's antibody
tasks or serology tests that are also
available that have euas from the fda
and we know that the antibody test will
look for the presence or a serology test
will look for the presence of antibodies
in the blood
um of a person uh to detect if the
body's immune response has detected the
infection and is reacting
as we know serology testing does not
detect the virus itself but only the
antibodies we make to the different
viral components
so in early days of an infection when
the immune response is still building up
um serology tests may be negative if the
antibodies are not at high enough
volumes to be detected by the assay yet
and two things to keep in mind with
serology or antibody testing that
currently antibody testing should not be
used to diagnose or to exclude active
covet infections so you don't use
serology to diagnose covet infection
and currently this could change in the
future
but currently
serology tests should not be used to
indicate the level of immunity or the
level of protection from the virus due
to either a vaccination or due to a
previous infection
there are several groups out there uh
studying um how we can use serology
tests to determine immunity but
currently to date the fda fda has not
given any emergency use authorization to
any serology test
to indicate any level of immunity again
from vaccination or approach previous
infection
so again with sars kobe 2 diagnostics uh
we start with an uh
collection so whether you're using the
gold standard of a nasopharyngeal
specimen on a
flock swab or you're using some other
type of sight or swab like a nasal swab
a throat swab
um collected on flocked nylon rayon
dacron dacron or foam you could also be
using saliva collection or throat washes
or gargles um as well as 3d sampling
devices
um this can be again as we've talked
about submitted to the laboratory in a
variety of different stabilization media
um such as viral transport media saline
pbs
nucleic acid media or indeed can be
submitted dry
so i hope i've impressed on you that the
collection and collection of transport
devices are truly essential components
of the pre-analytical process for
quality microbiology testing for not
only sars cov2 but for other respiratory
viruses as well
and with that
i would like to thank you all very much
for your attention today and i'll turn
it back over to our moderator
thank you susan for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the
saturation volume of each swab type
well thank you for the question and um
uh this might have been asked before i
went over this information um but on um
in the presentation on slide 13 and 14
you can see that i've listed the
absorption and the aleutian volumes of
both the regular size swabs those would
be the swabs that would be used for
nasal nary
collections and also throat collections
and also for the mini tipped swabs that
would probably be more apt to be used
for the nasal pharyngeal
uh collections that go back further into
the nasal passages so if you want to
check back on slides 13 and 14 i have um
a wrap swabs as well as foam as well as
well as the flock
nylon fiber in regular and mini tip that
have both the absorption and the release
volumes for you
okay thank you
next question
will the self collection home collection
receive fda authorization in the future
beyond the pandemic and also
will self-collection still be popular
amongst test centers after covid
well that's a good question and i think
that's anyone's guess
i think right now all the home testing
and home collection devices from
that the fda have put out are all
emergency use authorizations
we know that companies now especially
for their assays are putting in 510 case
to get full fda approval i think as i
mentioned the bio fire is now an assay
that does have full fda approval that
includes detection of covet 19.
i would imagine there's more test
manufacturers that are working for that
510k clearance and i wouldn't be
surprised if there will be collection
methods out there as well that currently
have an eua
that will be looking forward um to try
to get a full 510k approval from the fda
so i think it
you know it's it's kind of we've we've
opened this box and uh uh we start doing
it that way this way the genies out of
the bottle if you will might be a little
bit difficult to put the genie back in
the bottle but i guess time will tell
but i i would imagine that some of the
suppliers will be trying to go forward
with fda full approval for their
collection devices as well
okay thank you
next question
we've recently received questions
regarding the safety of the
sterilization method used for swabs can
you comment on how swabs are sterilized
and the safety of the sterilization
method
yes this question we've received
recently as well so thank you for asking
it to give us the opportunity to address
this there is some misinformation out
there about the safety of the
sterilization method used on swab
collection devices
swabs are sterilized using ethylene
oxide which is a gas and it's extremely
common when sterilizing medical
equipment so very commonly used and
while ethylene oxide can have a
carcinogenic effect on an individual if
they're exposed to very high
concentrations for long periods of time
there's no danger from the brief use of
a nasal swab in an individual
you can think of it kind of like a bit
like using bleach at home we know it's
not a problem to dilute out bleach or
other detergents to sterilize our
surfaces in our kitchens and our
bathrooms etc but no one would think
about drinking bleach we know that would
be incredibly dangerous
but we also know that it's safe to use
when you use it carefully and correctly
very much like the highly regulated
ethylene oxide sterilization
sterilization process that we use in
swab manufacturing
thank you for clarifying that
um our next question
in-home collection
how is adequacy
of the sample made sure
that's a good question and i don't know
that there is um a way to do that
certainly for home collections if
they're sent in to a laboratory um a
clear laboratory for molecular testing
um of course there's the human gene that
is assayed for in many of those
molecular collection and if the uh
the human gene is not detected then the
assay is not able to be read so that's
one way that you can assure that uh
specimen out that there has been
specimen added to the swab for antigen
tasks rapid antigen tests or other
antigen tests that that is not available
um so in those particular cases there's
really no way of
really determining adequacy of the
sample
all right thank you
our next question
you mentioned pb saline and utm is
that is one better than the other
are there still supply issues regarding
utm
um you know uh uh utm has has been
around for a long time and we know utm
was originally developed to stabilize
viruses for long periods of time for
viral culture
it has been used for decades now in
molecular testing as well
it certainly we have a lot more
information out there on the use of
viral transport media and utm for
molecular assays a ton more than we have
with pbs so um
it's
i would say that just because of the
information that we have that utm
probably does work better than pbs there
are probably i think the quest study
that i went over uh in the paper if you
look at the details of that study it may
give you some comparison of using saline
or pbs compared to some of the viral
transport media but with copan we've
tripled our covid related production in
2020
both of our swabs and our utm media and
we have a goal for this year to reach 1
billion
of flock swabs and 1 billion of spun
fiber swabs and one half billion of
universal transport media to be produced
in this year so manufacturers have
really really geared up over the last 18
months and there should not be an issue
with supply
supply chains and for utm and swabs um
it going forward into the future now
that's a caveat of course things could
change but um with all the the ramping
up that the
manufacturers have done um it is really
time to get back to make sure we're
collecting using um listed registered
products that we know have quality in
order to do our uh viral testing for
respiratory viruses
okay
thank you so much
um
there have been some questions about the
slides being made available and this
this seminars webinar will be
um available on demand
um there will be an email sent out
shortly
so it looks like we are out of time for
more questions um thank you again susan
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor copan diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time